BABATUNDE OGUNLADE:
Hello, everyone.
Today we're going to be
working through Goodie Bag
5, which is on electronic
materials, namely
semiconductors.
In order to follow
along, you'll need
a multimeter, a pair
of alligator clips,
some large LEDs--
I'll be using red,
white, blue, and green--
and some regular sized LEDs.
I'll be using red,
blue, and purple.
Our main objectives today
are to identify differently
colored LEDs by
irradiating them with light
across the visible
light spectrum.
And in the process, to
explore the relationship
between the bandgap
of a semiconductor
and its critical
absorption wavelength.
As we work through
the Goodie Bag,
I'd like you to think about
how the size of the bandgap
of material may influence
which wavelengths of light
you can absorb.
Let's get started.
First, connect your
black or negative lead
to the 10 amp port
on the multimeter,
and then your red
or positive lead
to the voltage
ohm milliamp port.
Then connect the probe end
of each respective lead
to one end of an alligator clip.
After you do this,
you should still
have two free ends of
the alligator clips.
Grab one of your small LEDs
and connect the free end
of the alligator clip
connected to the red lead probe
to the positive end of the LED.
This is the longer
leg of the LED.
And then connect
the other free end
that's connected to
the black lead probe
to the negative end of the LED.
That's the short leg of the LED.
Then turn on your
multimeter and set the dial
to 2,000 milli DC volts.
This is the order of
magnitude of voltage
we'll measure across
our small LEDs
when we irradiate them with
light from the larger LEDs.
Finally, make sure to
keep track of which small
LED you're testing
so that which LED
to refer to when
we start comparing
data between small LEDs.
So now we have our small LED
hooked up to our multimeter.
And now we're going to shine
each one of our large LEDs
onto the small LED and
record whether or not we have
some non-zero voltage reading.
If the large LED
has enough energy
to excite electrons across
the bandgap of the small LED,
we should see some non-zero
voltage across the small LED.
So first I'm going to try
and shine this blue light
onto my small LED, and I'm
going to look at the multimeter
and try to see if there's
some voltage drop.
As you can see, our
volt meter is now
measuring some
non-zero value, which
means that this blue light
has enough energy to excite
electrons across its bandgap.
After you've done this, repeat
this for the other large LEDs,
and then repeat the entire
experiment for the other two
small LEDs.
This should generate a
set of 12 data points.
And using our knowledge
of bandgaps and wavelength
absorption, as well as the
data that you've acquired,
we're going to determine
which small LED is what color.
So after running through
your experiments,
you should have some chart
that looks like mine, where
I have my small LEDs
going down the side here
and the large LEDs going across.
So each square
represents a time when
a small LED he was
irradiated by a large LED.
And a check represents when a
non-zero voltage was measured
across the multimeter,
and an x represents
when there was a
zero or very low
voltage reading across the LED.
So in order to dig
into what this means
it's important to
understand the balance
of the visible light spectrum in
terms of energy and wavelength.
So if you remember the
visible light spectrum,
known wonderfully by the
acronym ROYGBIV, where
you have red on one end and you
have violet on the other end,
we know that red
corresponds to around 700
nanometers in wavelength.
And we know that violet
or purple corresponds
to around 40 nanometers
of wavelength.
And if we think back to the
relationship between the energy
of light and its wavelength,
we know that the formula
is E equals hc over lambda.
So as the wavelength of light
decreases, the energy of light
increases.
So going across, as we go from
red, green, blue, and white,
we have increasing
energy because we
have decreasing wavelength.
And just as a reminder,
white is a composite
of red, blue, and green.
So it has all three of
these combined in it.
So now let's start to identify
which LED is what color.
So if you look at
small LED 1, it
was irradiated by red,
green, blue, and white light.
And there was a voltage drop
across the LED for all of them.
That means that
at the very least,
red had enough energy
to excite electrons
across the bandgap
of that small LED.
Because that's the
case, and we know
that we're dealing
with LEDs which
emit like in the
visible light spectrum,
we know that this small
LED then must be red.
So if we look at
small LED 2, we can
see that both red and
green light did not
have enough energy
to excite electrons
across the bandgap
of the second LED.
But when we shined blue
light onto the LED,
we got a non-zero voltage drop.
And the same thing when we
shined white light, which
also has blue light in it.
Because, like I said
at the beginning,
we knew that our small these
were red, blue, and purple,
and we've already
found our red LED,
that means that this
LED must be the blue.
So finally, if we look
at small LED number 3,
we can see that red, green,
blue, and white light
did not have sufficient energy
to cause some voltage drop
across the LED.
If we look back
to ROYGBIV, and we
think about the
energy of red to blue,
that means that they
didn't have enough energy
to excite anything after it.
And that means that our final
LED must be violent or purple.
So by shining light across
the visible light spectrum
onto our small LEDs,
we're able to identify
which one of our small
LEDs are what color.
So right here I have small LED
1 hooked up to the multimeter.
And we determined it was red.
And so we can check that
by just turning on the LED.
So as you can see,
this LED is shining
red, which means
it's the red LED,
and we're able to confirm that
by using our data as well.
You can check that
the other two LEDs
are the colors
that we determined
by doing the same thing.
So today we looked at a direct
application of semiconductors
in LEDs.
We looked at the relationship
between the bandgap of an LED,
of a semiconductor, and
the range of light that
can absorb across its bandgap.
We found that for
semiconductors, there
are some critical
absorption wavelengths,
some maximum wavelength, below
which the LED will absorb
all other wavelengths of light.